people flying from overseas will
experience new security measures
starting this morning the stricter rules
apply to all us-bound flights and are
aimed at responding to threats of hidden
explosives people from the US and other
countries could be interviewed by
airline employees and face more detailed
inspections of their electronic devices
now this measure will affect around 325
thousand passengers a day that's about
2,100 flights
Jericka Duncan is at New York's John F
Kennedy International Airport with more
on this story Jericka good morning good
morning five global airlines we'll start
what's known as these passengers
security interviews today that impacts
Air France cafe Pacific Egypt air
Emirates and Lufthansa the interviews
could be something as brief as at the
gate or they could actually be including
filling out a questionnaire and this
process could potentially slow up
boarding and even cause flight delays
Delta is reminding passengers traveling
into the United States to arrive at
airports at least three hours before
departure
now the Trump administration said four
months ago that Airlines had until today
to enhance screening procedures for
us-bound flights these new measures
essentially replaced that temporary
carry on laptop been impacting planes
coming from ten airports in eight
predominantly Muslim countries that
include Saudi Arabia Turkey Egypt Kuwait
Qatar the United Arab Emirates Jordan
and Morocco
now the domestic changes include things
like when you go through those TSA check
lines instead of only having to pull out
say your laptop any device that's bigger
than a cell phone has to come out of
your carry-on luggage and put in
separate bins so that it can be screened
again all of this could cause more
delays and possibly hold up the boarding
process Norah
alright tarika thank you